well Schoen own reject nice Shin is Greg
Alba he and I'm John you understand we
are going to watch Marvel Studios black
panther get this man issue you working
on your Russian African accent yeah
somebody get these men is shield
yes Russian Marvel Studios Black Panther
warriors of Wakanda today this feature
read today's patron the day shout-out is
gonna go out to none other than Tony
McGuire accept no substitutes
[Music]
responsibility he's an American
[Music]
pledge their lives to the throne and to
the security of the kingdom is the
represents the old guard a tradition by
all my character he had challenges
tradition the Kea was born to be a
warrior
[Music]
[Music]
it's real
don't breathe
[Music]
Wow that just got me so Jack way more
excited for the rest of the ensemble
I don't think truly factoring in to my
anticipation experience this is the
first time it's really clicked for me
that Wakanda is more than just like a
far-off place yeah like getting to kind
of see the dynamic and the different you
know roles the these people play in
their in their society here like is
awesome he's royalty you know yeah and
and they're like a badass military I had
read a little bit about the Dora mulashi
yeah the all-female special forces of
the Black Panther world and Wakanda I
didn't know how heavily featured they
would be in this it's like obviously you
see them in the trailer you know they're
gonna be supporting characters the
Knights of Ren what I loved about this
moment and watching this trailer was
that you do see they're gonna hone in on
them and they took a lot of special
attention in detail like that idea of
these tall female warriors working
together as one unit and then when they
were teasing that fight would kill
monger I was like oh now I'm really
looking forward to this fight you know
well yeah it looks like there's gonna be
a lot happening and there's probably
gonna be a lot of different kinds of
fights in this in this movie yeah a lot
of different kinds of combat to look
forward to like in this one at least
looking at this featurette like it looks
more like a film to me like the way
they're shooting and it just reminds me
of Christopher Nolan for some reason
like just the production values and the
way everything kind of looks so there
even though it is big and broad like I
feel like yeah might be them throwing
down on a different level because even
though what Kaunas teased at this as
this very technologically advanced world
which is going to be I was noting
especially alpha when Michael B Jordan
was saying it seems like when people are
fighting though they're just gonna
really be like stuntmen and fights and
choreography and I know that the black
panther suit will give him you know some
cool superpowers where he's like
flipping off cars and landing on other
ones and running up buildings like those
will still be awesome I get the
impression this will have a little bit
more of a grounded sense than maybe how
the trailers are currently been
communicating a little less you know
spaceships and fans yeah I have a
feeling they'll be a little bit more
grounded and really hone in on culture
which I'm really
looking forward to oh yeah we already
got our tickets for it opening night
can't wait yeah so yeah keep a lookout
for that
holy [ __ ] shadows men's American yeah
Chadwick Boseman
to leave the hype yeah I forgot that he
played Jackie Robinson and and James
Preston they hired an actual guy from
Africa Oh Tony McGuire my friend uh the
reason I wanted to give Tony McGuire
shout out on this video is because yes
he's a white boy living in Colorado but
if I know Tony he wants nothing more
than to be a black guy I think if you
just you know get a little bit more buff
you could probably hang out with some
more black people a little more often I
don't know I went to Colorado I got
recognized by a black guy in Colorado
which was cool I only got recognized by
one person and it was this black guy
okay and he was so happy to meet me and
I was like yay going off of that one
black guy that I saw and that's I think
you just got a mirror exactly him Tony
you got to get buff smile a little more
you know it's not a bad thing to smile
yeah like in LA you know a lot of black
people and they're very charming people
this may just really trying to make it
linked to Black Panther 42 and really is
starting to feel like get out so it's
perfect you got two black I don't want I
don't want to do that I'm gonna that far
just say that's where this sounds like
it's how I think he could be more like
Jamie Kennedy and Malibu's Most Wanted
well with more class black panther comes
out in just a couple weeks subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and become a patron
eject today it's a worthwhile experience
got well over 250 posts at least and
most of them are videos to go check them
out yeah